here's something that will be new to
some of you at least and which in my
opinion is the coolest logical operator
of all it really that some of its
properties are so nice you just go wow
that's great it's exclusive or let's
write down a truth table for this thing
the exclusive-or
is like the inclusive or it comes out as
true if either one of the inputs is a
one but not when both of them are a one
that's why it's called exclusive if
they're both one it doesn't matter the
one it comes out as a zero another way
to look at it is to say the outcomes 1
only if the two inputs differ if they're
the same then the outcomes the zero so
here we go a zero exclusive all of the
zero they're the same it's 0 a 1
exclusive order the 1 they're the same
so that's a 0 but a 1 with a 0 or a 0
with a 1 they're different so the
answers are 1 and for this reason the
exclusive or operation is sometimes
called and not equivalence operation net
as well as exclusive all but if we're
writing this down again in our
electronics engineer type notation how
do they like to write it down well this
one's a special favorite of mine it
doesn't just have a go faster fast back
to it it's got actually a double go
faster aerodynamic fast back like that
so you get your two inputs a B you get
your output here now how can you denote
a exclusive Ord with B well lots of ways
computer scientists would probably just
prefer to write out X or largely because
many assembler languages will have an
XOR operation and that's the way you
think about it but for example
mathematical magicians may prefer and
you very often see this so be aware of
it to put a plus inside a circle like
that and that's
that it's not the inclusive or for which
they use a plus sign on its own but it's
a special form of plus in fact as well
see in just a minute is precisely the
form of addition you need for a binary
adder circuit it really really is but
don't forget don't be thrown if you see
it written particularly in old textbooks
some of them like to call it the knot
equivalence operation a knot equivalent
with B let me just show you now what
happens if I exclusive or not just a
single bit with a single bit but let's
put this opposed we're doing a three bit
binary adder dead simple unsigned
addition no two's complement nothing
silly just straightforward vanilla
binary adder I'm going to write down one
zero one which is your Nellie's five I'm
going to write down zero one zero which
you all know is two and I'm going to put
between them a circle plus to show you
an exclusive or ring now watch what
happens from the right one exclusive Ord
with zero they differ
therefore the outcome is a 1 0 exclusive
order with one they differ the outcomes
are one I've done this very carefully
left-hand column one exclusive order
with zero
they still differ that's one five and
two is seven
that's magic all you've done is you just
it's binary adder to which my repost
will be yes it's a binary adder but I've
carefully drawn a veil over what would
happen if I had to carry a bit from one
position to the next because that needs
extra attention so think of it this way
the exclusive-or is what you want for
adding together all of the bits in a
given column in a binary adder the only
trouble is it doesn't take care of
carrying out a bit to the next column
along to the left I can now show you the
beginnings of how you could build or
draw a logic diagram filled favorite
electronics person to build for you a
one bit part binary adder it's
technically known I'll put it here as
half adder so if we focus in on this
just look at this first of all I'm
revising here up at the top here's what
we've now done we've done and/or
exclusive or not there's rather better
drawn and neater gates up there but just
look at this at the top you are now
recognized here is an exclusive or gate
with two inputs a and B the output of
those is called the sum it's the sum in
that column however if it so happens
that a and B are both 1 we know what
will happen with exclusive or it'll say
oh they're the same so I generate a 0
wow that's good that's the right answer
you want to generate a 0 but you want to
carry one so how do you generate the
so-called carryout bit the answer is in
parallel with the inputs a and B going
into the exclusive all you take them in
parallel as inputs to a NAND gate now
remember just what you're going to need
is that you will only carry if both of
the bits in that column were ones 1 and
1 is 0 and that means you must carry out
a 1 to the position to the left the
carry bit is the logical result of
handing together a and B and I've given
you now the truth table over here on the
right for the whole shebang
here you're a here's your B here's what
the carry bit must be it must be a 1
only if the two inputs are ones in the
second column here's the sum 1 if you're
adding Norton 1 or 1 and 0 if you're
adding two zeros it's obviously a 0 and
if you're adding 2 ones it's a 0 but
you've taken care of the carry out you
can see why that's called a half adder I
mean we relax back we have a glass of
champagne a pint of beer whatever turns
you on but you've only done half the job
because the hard bit is and I can hear
lots of you on the comments already
saying ah but what about carry in Here I
am in the middle of a 32-bit binary
addition slap-bang in the middle and on
column 15 but I've got to carry in
coming from my right as well as having
to give a carry out further over to the
yes well for those of you who are
hardcore or have seen it before
let me just finish this little excursion
by saying if you want to know what a
full one bit adder has to look like just
feast your eyes on this one here at the
top left here that's the main
exclusive-or that does the
straightforward addition of the digits
during that column that you're trying to
add at the moment down here at the
bottom is the carry out that we have
before but the complication now is
you've got to do the carry in how do you
do the carry in while you bring it in as
C subscript in it just comes in the
carry into this position is what the
carry out was from the previous position
that you've just done and you bring it
in here and I want you to work your way
through this and to convince yourself
that this is the right answer
the carry in bit will affect the carry
out bit because as we saw when we were
doing binary addition you sometimes get
a situation where they're carrying a one
but the two figures in the column to be
added are also ones so you can have one
plus one plus one right which is like
three which is like modulo-2 arithmetic
it's like a two to be carried but with a
remainder one
so one plus one plus one is right and a
one and carry one and this bit of the
circuit down here is the extended carry
House circuit which copes with the fact
that the carry in may have given you yet
another one to be added in as well as
the two ones that were in the column
already so here's the overall truth
table for everything folks your a and B
inputs in this particular column whether
you had a carry in or not was it naught
or one and in the light of all of those
just read across and you'll find out
what happens if n be a zero you have
zero carry in it's easy there is no
carry out and the sum of the two is zero
down here they're really hardest one of
all is if you've got an A and a B of one
and a carry in a one
that's going to be one down and carry
one so one on one at the bottom
intermediate you can check through
everything checks out just the way it
does so apart from all its other charms
which we've yet to discover the great
thing about exclusive-or is that it's
just what you need with a few extra and
gates and an or gate to do carryout
scary ins if you take care of all that
exclusive or is at the heart of what a
binary adder circuit has to have
faster tail thin there and it slips
round like this
there is your or gate with a a and a B